what do you make of this decision then
neil
well it comes sort of out of the blue
really we weren't really expecting i
know that see
that the channel was under uh
investigation it does seem
as if on the face of it that uh offcomer
have made this decision
based on the fact that this parent
company would not be
uh fully into fully in control of its
editorial policy
and that's the offcom rules i think we
need a wider debate here andrew about
what ofcom what ofcom's powers are
do we need them could we not have a
better system
and of course there will be those people
who would argue that this is uh
politically motivated and that's always
the problem here
we already know that we have the
president to press tv from iran
being taken off air losing its license
from ofcom about a decade or so ago
so people who will will argue or will
uh suspect perhaps the politics might
have played a part this we don't know
yeah it's do you think it's strange
about the timing in that you know cgtn
has been broadcasting for some time in
the uk so why
why make a fuss about this right now
surely you should have sorted this sort
of
thing out at the beginning
absolutely and the the reason why it's
licensed the extensible reason why it's
licensed has been removed is of course
this business about the parent company
not having editorial control
well wasn't that the case from the word
go hasn't that been the case
all along uh so it says seems strange
when we're hearing that it comes in a
year ago
a year on from from a criticism of the
channel's coverage of the hong kong
protest
show claims that they were biased in
their coverage again it seems strange
that we're now february 2021 and we have
this
decision taken now because surely if
those problems were there
uh already they've been there for a long
time and so yeah as you say it has been
broadcasting a long time in the uk
it's strange that this decision has
announced today we should note too that
ofcom didn't complain about the content
that was being broadcast by
cgtm but now it's gone or will go
i mean it leaves a hole doesn't it in
the media landscape because i know that
cgtn did provide
a chinese perspective which is you know
not often easily found
in the media absolutely let a hundred or
nfl
flowers bloom that's always been my
philosophy and that's why i think what i
said earlier we need to look
look deeper now and the question is sort
of what kind of media regulation do we
want
been very disturb as we all as we all
know who work for rt and
contribute to our trt has been subject
to a concerted
campaign by certain individuals to try
to get the channel off air
so lobby ofcom to take action political
uh pressures shouldn't come to play we
had the labour party
uh the the the leader of the labour
party uh and their spokesman
spokesperson on media first writing to
ofcom urging them to take action against
rt
this shouldn't be happening we shouldn't
have uh the politicization
of media regulation and as you say it's
great
to be able to put on your tv you want to
watch rt
here's some russian news you can see a
russian perspective for on the bbc put
on
cnn put on trt or turkish perspective
you have a chinese perspective which is
lost now
we used to have an iranian perspective
yeah i think people who generally suff
media pluralism and i'm one of those
people want to see as many channels as
we can possibly have so that viewers can
have
a proper view of you know different
countries from different perspectives
that's surely what
a democratic pluralistic media landscape
looks like that's why
i'm very worried about ofcom and
and how it operates and the pressures
that are put on to ofcom
neil really good to talk to you we're
going to have to leave it there that was
uh neil clark who's a uk based
journalist
speaking to us from oxford i think i'm
guessing thanks neil
you